je suis méchant moi je méchant je
méchant garçon
le docteur m'a dit quel âge tu as
j'ai 40 ans aux métiers grand oui je
suis grand
j'ai bavé single j'aime pas les petites
filles j'ai dis à la petite fille le
père noël liste d'auteurs macondé tu
n'aimes pas cette petite fille
entends-tu et son papa oui je suis son
papa qu'est ce qui est arrivé
pourtant que tu es été à l'école oui
école nationale d'administration ena et
tu te souviens de ce qu'on a appris et
non
tu te souviens de la chanson là vers les
chansons que tu chantais la situation
économique dans l'industrie nationale
est préoccupant j'aime pas jusqu'à
j'aime pas chirac j'aime papunya je
passe par le docteur maudit chers amis
c'est de la régression infantile et
gracia a senti le